[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[ __ ] your dog at least we're gonna be
[ __ ] up together right you know [ __ ]
it and and that's it Paul you [ __ ]
and you inform this [ __ ] bomb bro
that is unbreakable because at the end
of the day we're all little Warriors
we're all little men that were that were
not mentored the right way you pulled
this fire in us has to be this fire in
us has to be [ __ ] dealt with you know
but if there's nowhere to deal with it
you're gonna [ __ ] you max out you
know in whatever way and that's it bro
you know it's it's it's that love and
then that's it that's it you can't break
that [ __ ] right [ __ ] are dying
out there bro [ __ ] my boy dies my
boys getting loud my best friend got
life at 15.
you know so it was that you know Boeing
yeah and then by the time you're 15 your
mind shifts for like [ __ ]
sit you know I'm growing up in jail my
friends are getting live and
[ __ ] are getting smoke Let's
Roll
let's roll let's [ __ ] let's let's do
this [ __ ] you know and then I could tell
you it wasn't until [ __ ] I fought a
life sentence I I shot I shot a man and
you start late and they're trying to
give me 35 years to life bro I was 20
years old
and and that one got me that one [ __ ]
me up that one shifted me because like
you just see all your life 19 years
straight [ __ ] my son was like one
and then you're just like
it's just like [ __ ] like this is what it
is you know people have a 35 year life
to [ __ ] you have sentence on you you
know
and then
and then you just [ __ ] just like
you're just thinking about life bro you
know that whole year at Southern L.A
County Jail I said in Alley County jail
for 11 months bro [ __ ] 35 35 so I
kept on hearing me playing my [ __ ]
mind 35 years to life how old am I gonna
be
you don't want to shifts your body
changes you it's done you know and
[ __ ] through the grace of God Bro
[ __ ] can I remember the week before
weeks before trial right
[ __ ] because so what happened bro is
that
on pre-trial this fool said that I was
there but he said I didn't shoot him
so that was enough to send me the trial
but it wasn't enough to [ __ ] so it
wasn't an open showcase right like we're
gonna have we're gonna we're gonna have
a trial right but it was enough to
convict me for gang Association they had
enough to convict me for gang
Association were you pleading not guilty
I [ __ ] play Not Guilty Bro [ __ ] yeah
I did bro because so this is what
happened boom boom boom boom boom when I
[ __ ] 19 years old bro you wanna walk
into the night please all right [ __ ]
well I'm with the boys my son's like one
bro and I like and then start bro like
those are my friends right like I know
that I need to do good but like those
are my friends and like it just becomes
one of those nights we're drinking right
we're drinking and I and I don't and and
I don't give it wasn't the alcohols but
it influenced it of course right and
that kind of changed my whole view of
alcohol after right we're at the
Commerce Casino
[ __ ] all the boys are there and we
hit the hood
and [ __ ] um and it's me and my own
boy it's me and Demon
the [ __ ] um we're striking up
we're heading up the hood right
and I remember I had that burner on me
not in my back pocket I was crazy I
didn't have I didn't never used to carry
guns at that time right but for some
reason [ __ ] other people put the
[ __ ] right here right
and then uh and and demon demon gets off
boom I post my position right boom I got
his back boom anybody comes I'm on them
right cops or whatever I'm giving it to
him right that's just and and for the
folks who don't know you're tagging it
wrong
[ __ ] graffiti on the wall spray cane
is happening can you just also just
explain what so so this yes yes yes this
is territorial this is territorial Los
Angeles
we're striking up our [ __ ] territory
to let you [ __ ] know where the
[ __ ] you're at which is a very dangerous
Endeavor yeah so with that so with with
that right but in my young mind I
already know what's up right homeboy
position homeboy's on the [ __ ] thing
I'm on the corner with the burner right
anybody comes cops come [ __ ] fools
come boom I'm giving it to him
that's it so but I've been drinking so I
see these fools on the corner
and he's demon I [ __ ] up I leave them
bro I have the murders
I leave
I swear to God I leave them I leave them
I run up on these fools happening right
but these ones have been tricky too and
and bro the big [ __ ] the big
[ __ ] he was like
and she's like I don't give a [ __ ]
right
this looks too big bro I can't but I'm
looking on them right
boom boom he [ __ ] Falls like I
remember him falling over me bro and
[ __ ] demons in my rescue demons he's
on it right [ __ ] he comes and Booms
are stomping this WOW boom boom boom
boom boom
I get up
and I just boom I don't remember but I
just don't remember I [ __ ] just pull
out the burner bro and I just thought
boom boom
I'm [ __ ] one of them hit him bro one
of them hit him you saw it
they scattered he starts he turns
and but by the time turn I already had
hit him and [ __ ] yeah and boom we're
gone we're gone bro we're gone we're
gone and [ __ ] um I I um the next day
they already knew because
they go with a six-pack Boop
demon boom boom boom boom right there
right there boom [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I
remember that morning bro the next
morning
I'm going I'm an electrician at the time
right I'm getting ready for work and I
get a car
and it's my homeboy it's my boy Tremaine
and he's like hey Bo what happened last
night
and he was like they're looking for you
bro
and boom I remember crying
remember I broke down I remember I was
sitting in my mom's [ __ ] stairs in
Santa Fe Springs
I hung up the phone and I [ __ ] broke
and my life changed and my life changed
right there and that was it and I was it
they hit my grandma's house that night
I'm on a battle
and I went on the run I wanted to I want
to run the run I went on the Run of
Texas I went on my I'm one of the rental
apostle
see my dad you know
and then can you walk me through that
going on the run like with that like
what what what's your emotional state
right you're just like demon [ __ ] we
hit it demon [ __ ] goals they start
hitting houses bro they start hitting
the homies houses looking for us right I
don't know if this one's dead or what
you know you just knowing that he's
[ __ ] looking for you right and you
[ __ ] grandma calls you know [ __ ]
they come in like [ __ ] SWAT team goes
to my grandma's house and my uncle I
remember my uncle was was living he was
there that night and then they he seen
him you know and he was like he's not
here but they were [ __ ] he said they
were ready but the thing is it's crazy
because my mom used to work from
Montebello police when I was a little
boy so I think that's another reason why
they didn't just kick down the door you
know they knocked Jason
you know you know hey you know this is
you know Lourdes is [ __ ] like it was
like that type of [ __ ] like sergeants
that [ __ ] a we're just you know yeah
yeah bro and that was it [ __ ] it was
gold time demon went to the desert and I
went to Texas bro and and it was just
like let's see how this [ __ ] unfolds you
know
and um I was sitting and I'll pass with
my dad and he was like you could go to
Mexico soon he had a house you know
and I was like [ __ ] I remember sitting
there like in his yard and like my son
was one
you gave me my song was one two bro like
it was that type of [ __ ] like I remember
when I left my son like [ __ ] I might
never see him he was like he didn't know
he was like you don't want to stop bro
you're just like [ __ ] like
and then I hear that
I hear that that dude survived and that
he's not gonna snitch
and that the reason why he's not going
to snitch is because he wants his run
back
and I was like cool
I'll [ __ ] deal with that right I'll
[ __ ] here I'll [ __ ] take one right
whatever we'll see each other I'll take
that [ __ ]
and instead of going to Mexico I trust
that bro and I was like [ __ ] it let's go
and I turn myself in WoW
cheer myself in bro I threw myself in at
the Montevallo police station can you
can you walk me through that choice and
yeah
so [ __ ] we go bro
and um
and it was like yeah I didn't want to be
like I knew what that word like that's
it bro On The Run you're never coming
back I knew I knew you know I don't
understand I was like I didn't kill this
[ __ ] I know they're gonna try to
wash me up but I didn't kill his ass you
know so [ __ ] it let's face the music
baby because it was that like [ __ ] it
like here this is what my life is right
let's face this [ __ ] I went to the
county jail on my 18th birthday so I
already had [ __ ] you know County Jail
experience and what they say about the
LA County Jail that if you could survive
the LA County Jail you could survive any
[ __ ] prison in the United States do
you agree with that [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah bro it's it's there's yeah bro
it's dark the dungeons bro right so I
don't know if this is gonna make it or
what but I don't have no money bro I'm
[ __ ] so the only way to make money in
the county jail is to sell [ __ ] dope
right I need you know like if they know
if I don't got no money my mommy gonna
send me [ __ ] my girl ain't gonna send me
[ __ ] so y'all bro that [ __ ] that that
starts off my my um
the trials in both yeah and then 11
months in the county jail and then so
the week before brother the week before
I go to trial
um the judge she tells me um Mr Cabral
I know you want to go to trial but we
have an offer for 13 years
and [ __ ] she didn't even [ __ ] wait
for me to reply but she was like the way
you're looking at me right now I know
you're not gonna take it and I was like
nah I ain't gonna take it because the
max for the gang allegations was 10
years
the gang no the authentic murder was 25
so I knew I could be the attempt to
murder and if they they could only Max
me out for 10 years you knew he wasn't
going to snitch
bro on the [ __ ] pre-trial right so
it's the [ __ ] big thing he comes bro
he comes
and he gets up there bro and it's the
big question is Richard Cobra is the man
that shot you right here is he here
today
and he looked at me and he said no
he said no bro you know so it was like
but they were still trying to push this
[ __ ] you get me what do you think his
motivation was for saying because he
wanted
himself yeah yeah cool
[Music]
foreign